- My experience of American
food is, sometimes,
there's strange ingredients.
So when I try something
new, I get a bit nervous,
in case it might kill me.
(fiddle music)
- Uh, biscuits and gravy
sounds exceptionally weird.
- Biscuit in England
is basically a cookie,
and gravy is usually what you put on,
like, mashed potatoes or roast dinner.
So, biscuits and gravy are two things
that should never be put together.
- Honestly, it looks like sick.
- Um, it looks like a cake
with carbonara sauce on it.
- It smells like car tires.
- Bottoms up.
(eating sounds)
- It's horrible.
- Mmmmm, well.
- This should be for prisoners!
- It doesn't taste like anything, really.
- Salty. That is so salty.
- It's like, you know that spray you get,
smoke spray you can, like, add to things?
It's like someone just went like
all over it.
- I don't, I don't mind
the gravy. It's creamy.
- Yeah, if you just had
the sauce on its own,
it just tastes like a really
cheap microwave pasta dish.
But then, you can't ignore
that 90% of it is the gone-off sponge.
- It's not disgusting.
Like, I don't hate it.
- I mean, I can see it
probably fills you up.
If you're hungry, like student food.
- Maybe Americans would like it.
I don't think English people
would ever enjoy this,
especially at breakfast.
- We call these scones, back home,
and you would put jam and cream on them.
- England has a lot of strange foods
that we think are normal,
and just coming out to America,
I realize how strange our
cuisine seems to people.
- This is not something
I would seek out again.
It doesn't taste amazing.
Um, but I can imagine, if
you've grown up with it,
it would give you a sense of comfort.
It is that comfort food.
- And, it doesn't make sense in my brain,
because we grew up with
something completely different.
So, it's just a cultural difference,
and we shouldn't really
be too mean about it.
- It's just so sad, what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah, mm-hmm. (whoosh of air)
(drum solo music)
You don't know the half of it.
(calm piano music)